lo que tenemos aquí es x definida en
términos de t
definida también en términos de t y
luego si tuvieran que graficar sobre
todos los valores de t
obtendrían una gráfica muy genial justo
como esta y lo podemos probar no se
podemos pensar en t igual a cero y
encontrar cuáles son sus
correspondientes xy james y también lo
podríamos probar no sé contigua la uno y
encontrar cuáles son sus
correspondientes xy james y también para
todas las demás de esas y así
obtendríamos una gráfica tan genial como
ésta pero el objetivo del vídeo no es
sólo apreciar la genialidad de las
gráficas o las curvas definidas por
ecuaciones paramétricas en realidad lo
que queremos es hacer un poco de cálculo
y en particular queremos encontrar esta
vez queremos encontrar cuál es la
derivada de g
con respecto a x con respecto a x en y
bueno vamos a tomarnos un cierto valor
así que qué te parece si nos fijamos en
esta derivada cuando y se me ocurre
tomar un valor de t así que qué te
parece si calculamos esta derivada
cuando te m es igual a no sé es igual a
menos un tercio muy bien cuánto va a ser
esta derivada de aquí y si están
inspirados los invito a pausar el vídeo
y tratar de resolver esto yo estoy a
punto de hacerlo con ustedes en dado
caso de que ya lo hayan hecho o si
quieren que yo lo haga así que la clave
es cómo encontramos la derivada de que
con respecto a x déjame notarlo cómo
podemos encontrar la derivada de qué
con respecto a x bueno esta derivada y
aquí está la clave de este vídeo va a
ser igual a la derivada de game con
respecto a t la derivada de james con
respecto a t esto a su vez dividido
entre la derivada de x la derivada de x
con respecto a t aquí está la clave de
este vídeo si fueras a ver estos
diferenciales como números esto
funcionaría matemáticamente bien ahora
esto puede llegar a ser un poco no
riguroso cuando empiezas a hacerlo pero
si lo piensas y es una manera fácil de
pensar acerca del por qué esto en
realidad podría tener sentido la
derivada de ye con respecto a x sería
igual pues la derivada de ye con
respecto a t entre la derivada de x con
respecto a t muy bien entonces como nos
ayuda a esto bueno porque podemos
encontrar la derivada de aquí lo tenemos
vamos a buscarla
derivada de x con respecto a t
ok y esto simplemente va a ser bueno
aplicar la regla de la cadena
tengo la derivada de lo exterior es
decir la derivada de dos veces el seno
esto con respecto al interior me
quedarían dos veces el coseno de bueno
de lo mismo de uno más tres t ya esto
habrá que multiplicarlo por la derivada
del interior la derivada de esta función
que tenemos aquí y bueno eso es muy
fácil la derivada de un hombre es cero
esto se va y me queda solamente la
derivada de tres t con respecto a t lo
cual es simplemente 3 así que a esto lo
multiplicamos por 3
ahora la derivada de que con respecto a
t eso es más sencillo la derivada de
james con respecto a t es simplemente
aplicar la regla de las potencias
me va a quedar 3 por 2 lo cual es 66 cm
elevado a la 3 -1 lo cual es 26 de
cuadrada y entonces esto ya lo podemos
escribir como bueno tengo arriba a 6
temp cuadrada esto a su vez está
dividido entre y aquí abajo tengo 3 por
2 lo cual es 66 veces el seno de uno más
ok pero de aquí podemos cancelar estos
26 es este 6 16 se van y entonces me
quedan simplemente esto va a ser igual a
de cuadrada
cuadrada esto a su vez dividido entre el
co seno de uno más tres t de lujo esto
es a lo que equivale la derivada de ye
con respecto a x pero nosotros queremos
evaluar esta derivada cuando tema es
igual a menos un tercio así que vamos a
hacerlo entonces en este valor cuánto va
a valer mi derivada bueno pues aquí me
quedaría déjame ponerlo aquí me quedaría
de cuadrada lo cual sería menos un
tercio esto elevado al cuadrado esto a
su vez está dividido entre el coseno de
quien bueno me quedaría uno más tres por
menos un tercio pero tres x menos un
tercio es menos uno y uno menos 10 así
que me quedaría el coseno de cero y
bueno esto de aquí es simplemente 1 así
que puedo decir que me la derivada de ye
gon respecto a x cuando te es igual a
menos un tercio
igual a un noveno y ahora podemos hacer
una pequeña tabla para ver cómo se ve
esto si me fijo en tem y por otra parte
me fijo en equis y por otra parte me
fijo en james en este valor de menos un
tercio que tengo menos un tercio bueno
cuando te es igual a menos un tercio
aquí que me quedaría me quedaría uno más
tres por menos un tercio es el seno de
cero el seno de 00 por dos me va a
quedar 0 y en james en que tengo menos
un tercio elevado al cubo es menos 1
entre 27 por 2 me queda menos
2 sobre 27 eso quiere decir que nos
estamos fijando en el punto cero coma
menos 2 entre 27 así que es el punto que
tenemos por aquí es el punto donde
estamos tratando de encontrar la
pendiente de la recta tangente y ya
sabemos lo acabamos de encontrar que la
pendiente de la recta tangente es un
noveno
así que una forma de pensarlo es que si
nos movemos cuatro unidades y media
hacia la derecha una dos tres cuatro y
media y media hacia arriba por aquí
entonces podemos dibujar la recta
tangente que se va a ver más o menos así
por acáp también me puedo mover no sé
cuatro unidades y media una dos tres
cuatro y media y media hacia abajo se
vería más o menos así esta sería una
buena aproximación de mi recta tangente
de la cual ya encontramos su pendiente
la pendiente es de un noveno y no
solamente es agradable a la vista sino
que supongo también es algo útil